[Music]
[Music]
according to a widespread assumption the
topic on which I'm going to deliver a
talk today does not belong in
linguistics proper as a matter of fact
giving this talk here in the MIT
environment is not quite irrelevant why
because this is the place from which 45
years ago a new trend in linguistics
originated the MIT as you know as you
may know among the tenets of this new
paradigm was the idea that language is a
phenomenon who study is part are the
cognitive sciences and ultimately of
biology I am NOT among those who work
within this theoretical framework which
appeared in linguistics in the middle of
the 20th century therefore I do not
think that languages can fruitfully be
studied only in cognitive thought of
being studied also in violin let alone
in biological terms sort of being
studied also in sociological terms to me
language is also to a great extent a
social phenomenon we also need social
linguistics verse I'm going to treat
here language death as a social
linguistics phenomenon this talk takes
most of its ideas from this book what
did I put it
I'll tell em all day long a who's trans
English translation will appear as far
as a young informed in country to watch
an ounce of or she was not supposed to
know it will appear in Stanford
University Press within hopefully one
year or probably I'm afraid more under
the title I don't know their title I
suggested hotting language death but
this was frowned upon as quite an
English well so anyway it will
here in an English version within more
or less than one year so that right now
I am drawing main the main of my
inspirations and ideas from the French
version which I wrote two years ago I
would also like to mention the name of
my friend and colleague Ken Hale whose
untimely death two weeks ago three weeks
ago one week ago is a terrible loss for
us linguists professional linguists
language death happens to be turns out
to be also one of the many topics which
he studied very brightly so he would be
mourned and this a great loss for us all
the more scenes as you know this was the
place where he taught okay let me
announce the plan I will try to follow
during much more than forty minutes
first the state of the or the situation
of languages as being on the brink of
extinction for most of them then the
causes of this phenomenon then the
results of these causes then the the
attempts at a certain revival attempt to
revive some languages according to
processes in which I will try to give
you some indications and then some
exceptions which can be studied in the
framework of so-called resurrection
which has been announced in the title so
state of the art what is the situation
today under our eyes a very simple
grossly presented 25 languages die every
year and the result of this cruel
calculation is that in to 100
considering that we have this is a
strict assessment 5000 languages without
thinking to account the directs I mean
this is a it's probably more considering
this number of 5000 languages since 25
of them die every year in to 100 we were
have two thousand and five hundred
languages which for me language lover
since childhood is a tragedy of course
some of some of you probably and some of
my colleagues even although they are
professional linguist like me and many
people in the mass don't care this does
not prevent them from sleeping very
quite fully it does as far as I'm
concerned and I would explain why we
could consider the situation normal but
I do not you probably know that in the
19th century there was they used to be a
what we can call a vitalist tradition
the ITA L ist which consisted of
studying languages in biological terms
and since the notion of death just like
the notion of life biological notions
applied to living species they were born
they live and then they disappear not
quite not completely but they disappear
as entities which are succeeded by new
entities which they produced or
generated so this formulation language
death language life the life of language
the title of many books in linguistics
in this century in an Austen 19th
century can be frowned upon as
metaphoric but they are not quite an
unscientific they correspond to a
certain a part of the truth so speaking
of language death their metaphoric to a
large extent is not quite to be ruled
out and what does it mean what is the
lifespan of a language of a human
language it begins when it appears then
it leaves for some time according to the
circumstances and the environment in
which it appears and then it generally
disappears
however these properties which allow us
to study languages in more or less
metaphorical biological terms are not
all of them especially particular
features of languages there is one which
does not which has never been mentioned
far as living species are concerns and
which must be mentioned as far as
language are concerned and this is the
possibility not to die completely
languages can be resurrected and this is
what I will try if if she leaves me time
for that to refer to at the end of this
talk well okay
when languages appear they their life
the lifespan the way they developed has
many features which as I said are common
with other speech since I accept this
metaphorical formulation this wording
like other species living species of the
ology of biography botanics and of
various sub branches entomology and so
on serie of insects of other living
species and to that extent languages can
be characterized as species which live
and which change when do we think
languages should not be confused with
language as a faculty languages a
faculty as you may know is a defining
property of our species human species is
characterized if not defined practically
exclusively by possessing in its genetic
code the what Chomsky himself here
refers to using the French terms as
fragmented along the Irish language
faculty the faculty the language which
was used by the French philosopher
decoct
whom Chomsky know as well and to whom he
devoted one whole book is what defines
us this means that in - to millions two
thousand of hundred years which is
reputed to be the probable date when our
species appears in a particular niche
in East Africa as you may know since
this time - before the Christian era we
have language it defines us because it
appears in our genetic codes but
languages English which has the same
word does not permit us to distinct
distinguish as French does which says
Lelong a little girls so long as a long
another same term English is forced to
use either the singular or the plural in
order to refer to these two notions and
language as a defining property of human
species is something which does not
necessarily result in languages at once
so although this is quite hypothetical I
suppose I think languages in the plural
appeared much later than the species
itself but as soon as the species
appears the only thing which
characterizes it as distinct from other
we are a species we are in anymore
species of course but the only thing
which distinguishes us from other animal
species is the inscription of language
in our genetic code and the last Apes
which are still Apes and the first
hominids which are already human humans
are distinguished not by the capacity of
their skull not by measures of their
morphological being but exclusively by
the position or not position of the fact
that we possess or do not possess this
Faculty language in their code well
later much later I mean close to our
period probably end of the Neolithic era
- 1012 thousand before Christ we
probably had this is a hypothesis but it
is probably propped by many arguments
which I cannot mention here for lack of
time for lack of time it was the period
in which many languages appeared and the
reason is not far to seek why do so many
languages appear
until the beginning of the Neolithic
just because this is the period when
human societies become societies in fact
by becoming centuries they were nomads
izing so far and approximately at that
period they begin to build cities and
building cities means to become peasants
to have an activity which is
agricultural and also to cease to stop
to a large extent without completely
stopping being what we call
hunter-gatherer hunter-gatherer is a
characteristic still represented in
Australia Australia in in some parts of
New Guinea and other parts of the world
which characterizes very old societies
the first ones I do not
I am eloquent I am loath to call them
primitive of course the as so many
people do because this would be a value
judgment against which I am completely
but I would just say that the societies
which are which were which used to be
and which for some of them still
existing are yet still hunter-gatherers
are of course nomads normalizing
societies because they just live from
what they hunt and what they gather or
we gathering and get a hunter-gatherer
implies fishing although when you hunt
you don't fish better fishing is just
put together always hunting as a means
of subsistence and these societies were
at the most ancient we know as soon as
they become sedentary and stop to some
extent and for some of them completely
being nomads
stop luminizing then they build cities
we can say without contradiction without
provocation that building cities is the
same as becoming peasants because when
you build cities you build them in the
lands so the French humorist Alfonzo Lee
said Oliver a completely Vila companion
but of course this is not this was a
provocation but in fact where can we
build cities if not in the
I mean in in the within the landscape
and then when we build cities the ones
which are cited by the Bible like
Jericho reputed to be probably wrongly
one of the most ancient one it remotes
too it goes back to it must be much
remote antiquity but not the most remote
one I mean probably nine thousand years
before the beginning of the Christian
era anyway whatever the first known city
Jericho or any other one building these
cities implies necessarily that people
these societies became we're becoming
Agriculture's and therefore they seized
normalizing and due to the complications
of the relationships they multiplied the
number of their languages so we are
quite sure very sure that the number of
languages grew considerably when human
societies became sedentary societies
this meaning that implying that
relationship are more more and more
complex when societies once they are
established settled anyplace have new
kinds of relationships which forced them
to to build new kinds of conception the
world's and to study it and to express
it with a much more refined
communication means which language well
this concerns the Neolithic but then
after this birth and development at a
period which is very close to ours
Renaissance or beginning of the
sixteenth century there is a sharp
decrease in the number of languages and
this is essentially due to the discovery
of new worlds which is a war like a
hawkish discovery people do not discover
a new world just by observing its
characteristics they murder the people
and this is one of the first causes of
language death they lead them to
the brink of extinction I mean both
ethnically and linguistically the ones
which who escaped Western violence lose
the languages and the ones who do not
lose the life and in the same time their
languages and their cultures so we know
that the number of languages is
submitted to a sharp decrease in the
beginning of the 15th century which is
by the way the beginning of what are
called the most beautiful discoveries of
the world by most of the time Westerners
well this implies that in America three
parts of America in Australia later in
New Zealand in Russia also languages
after having thrived after having been
extremely numerous become decreasing at
a very rapid speeds and in Africa
Nigeria Tanzania Kenya we also see many
many languages appearing for causes
which I'm going to study now so I have
just to begin with present to the
situation what I call the state of the
art and now let me prepare you some
causes the first cause which is quite
easy to understand is as I said physical
extinction of course when you when there
is slaughter when you kill people they
disappear and the languages appear at
the same time so this is the history of
the great part of the world we can say
that the discovery of North Central and
South America is the discovery of
continents in which Europeans not
mingling most of the time with some
exceptions the Spanish mingled much more
easily than the anglo-saxon Puritans
with the Indians
of course they needed women so
not mingling in general with the native
populations but pushing them further
away from their settlements or killing
them more by the spread of old-world
diseases than in wars led their language
and themselves to extinction this is one
of the chief causes now we also have
social and professional causes I mean
when the language is presented as
providing new jobs or as being the
vector of new values social values even
cultural values which correspond to an
enrichment and the possibility to affirm
oneself more readily then people switch
from their ancestral language from their
vernacular language to this new language
which was imputed to bring a new kind of
living judged preferable so this is what
happens in many places and especially in
America and in Africa so the second coat
of language extinction after physical
extinction itself is social and
professional changes under contacts in
Africa for example this example will
illustrate the way languages are led to
the brink of extinction
not necessarily by Westerners but also
by African themselves in the
relationship with other Africans when if
I am a nobody I am a I have nothing to
live off and I just hunt and gather and
I marry a woman whose father has cattle
since I I buy her women are bought of
her of course in this societies women
are bought and since for her father in
order to negotiate this commercial act
with me gives me some heads of cattle
which he has a she belongs to a family
in which people are
Pasteur's then I changed my where life
and from this Nomad izing life which I
had formerly to the new life which is
brought to me by my my 'rich I become a
new kind of man that mean that I give up
my formalizing life then the question
which appears as the main one is what
language will be transmitted to the
children of course the woman whatever
kind of feelings she has for her
husband's would not learn his language
what would we do she will transmit her
the language of her father the one of
her tribes which is hers and then the
children will be brought up in the
language of the mother and this is one
of the main social and professional
causes of their is appearing or
languages so marriage is every dangerous
things for languages it depends it
depends what kind of marriage but in
that particular case it's unfortunately
totally counterindicated another cause
is the models provided by urban life
therefore the priest the previous one
which I was referring to just seven
years ago I will illustrate probably by
the example of Quay gu who are a
normalizing population who were used to
be formally but they have changed the
real life in Kenya and most of them by
this kind of marriages to which I was
referring become pastors and in some
kinds they also they are cultivators and
then their language dies because they
they won't transmit it and this is the
case of this quagle
marrying Maasai women in Kenya and South
of Tanzania as far as the other course
is concerned to which models which are
provided by a new urban life a case
which I could mention is the
one of the Nubians of hi Egypt these
people belong to an earthly which has a
nilo-saharan language Nubian well
studied by linguists myself III did
field work on this language some years
ago and they are Muslims and since they
are Muslims they are very regularly
submitted to the religious emissions of
broadcasting's of Cairo in Arabic so
they become bilinguals
they speak their nubian vernacular
language and they also speak Arabic
which is the vector of Islam and which
they catch when they listen or watch the
broadcasting and television programs in
Arabic so this they do in urban centers
because in their countries it's
difficult to catch these media but when
they go to Cairo or to other important
series of Egypt and Sudan then they
progressively abandon give up their own
language and this is the way by which
life in urban centers is threatening is
a very big threat for the maintain
maintaining of languages so this is the
way most of them die another one which I
would like to refer to although it does
not belong as the previous ones to those
which can be studied scientifically I
mean using scientific concepts such as
professional life change of way of life
lifestyle marry and so on is a reason
which I am to some extent hesitant to
mention but I don't see any other reason
for the extinction of many languages in
the modern world that what I would call
I would refer to as snobbish tree in
many cases the adoption of English
precisely by populations which do not
need it neither in their social life nor
in their professional life nor for
commercial economic reasons is not
explainable short of referring to
reasons of snobbery this is the case in
many European countries in which English
is promoted not by the pressure of
British or American authorities not by
people who are themselves bearers I
would say or speakers of English but by
the very populations of European
countries Western countries in Europe
who consider which is by no means my
case of course they're speaking English
is something which is prestigious I
cannot share this ridiculous attitude of
course but it is the one we see in many
many Western media and especially in the
bourgeoisie in France Germany Spain
Italy and so on and the reason why I
mentioned at the end of this subchapter
on unconscious of language extinction
vision why I mention it at the end is
that snobbishly as I said cannot be
proposed as a scientific cause but it is
at any rate it is the only one I see
when I don't when I can't mention other
causes to explain switching from one
language to another one which one does
not really need as far as commerce and
profits the only the only care of these
kind of people is concerns selling or
buying in English as they think they are
forced to does not by any means improve
their business nor leads them to a
better kind of invention or creativity
and so on but nevertheless they think
that switching to English is something
which is to be praised well now let me
present the results of such a situation
I will give some examples to illustrate
the set of causes and
to show what this causes have brought
about as a result let me take these
examples in various parts of the world
and let me begin with an example in the
United States of Norwegian which you
might some of you might know probably
some of you who have a no vision
background have heard of that after an
initial migration of 1925 persons very
few Norwegians emigrated to the United
States in such numbers that they were
able to create innovation America and
this Norwegian America flourished from 8
1850 to 1940 during most of this period
the chief medium of internal
communication oral and written was a
Norwegian language which served as an
in-group identity marker widely spoken
in several parts of as you know of
Minnesota Wisconsin Ohio Indiana Iowa
South and North Dakota and some other
states research on informant usage shows
that I had myself done some fieldwork of
this in some of the states which I have
just mentioned shows that in the more
conservative and isolated rural
settlements the language persisted well
into the second that is the first
American generation as late as the 1940s
which means very recently one could
still find speakers who claimed to be
using original regularly in the United
States at least 1/2 of the time however
among these bilinguals Norwegian became
typically a family or neighborhood
language gradually abandoned as contacts
with American institutions and
individuals grew several informants
reported that they had first learned
English at this school at school after
speaking only Norwegian in their home
the discipline could be traumatic and
informal told me that at the district
school I am mentioning what he said we
were not allowed to speak Norwegian
another one puts it that when we were
little we could not talk Yankee and
teacher would keep us after school if we
didn't if we did the school was of
course not alone in promoting English
several mentioned contacts in the
Norwegian neighbors especially Irish and
Germans though there was an occasional
German who learn Norwegian from
surroundings are also to be mentioned
among the causes after world war ii
world war ii norwegian almost is
appeared as a as a result of all the
factors which i have mentioned the
scenario here outlined does not seem to
be very different from that which
applies to most immigrants languages in
the United States and also in Canada to
some extent in other parts of the world
which are now from the majority English
speaking there are special profiles
however for example for Pennsylvania
German where immigration was early and
massive in a comparison of various more
modern groups numbers and religious
boundaries may lead to greater
retentiveness as with American Germans
or too less as in the case of American
Danes English is not only the proto
American language of choice promoted by
official and private usage it is also
the lingua franca of all the earlier
immigrants who are sooner or later
driven to communicate with each other
and this is the fate of Norwegian in
this country let me mention another
example which has to do with Castilian
eyes or Hispanic South and Central
America in this in these countries as
you know we had a very great number of
local languages especially in Mexico now
what in the north and the Mayan
languages in the south as well as some
other ones in antic and so on which can
still be studied by people doing
fieldwork like myself but which are more
more or less or a great number of them
on the brink of extinction today
unfortunately these languages these
people lost their languages and their
cultures to the
Spanish culture to the Spanish language
and this was to a large extent due to
evangelization to Christianization and
also to the fact that just the same
colonial habit which which we see so
many examples all over the world people
when they colonize or when they arrived
in these countries took the best lands
took the best places to cultivate and
pushed away father and father the
original inhabitants who of course
either died because they have nothing to
eat or because they did not develop anti
elements to defend themselves against
the diseases brought by Europeans so
what happens to their body happened to
their languages another case is the
formation of new languages which is not
the same thing as the one am referring
to now I mean either language is imposed
upon in forests forced on people who are
deprived by the same token of their own
language and in that case it is a
substitution or another way another
person process by which we can say that
we have language death a language splits
into other languages and by splitting it
becomes other languages which do not
necessarily replace it but are its
outgrowth or ear its products this is
exactly what I am striving in my own
very poor terms what has happened to
French Italian Spanish Romanian and
Portuguese the so called near Latin or
Roman languages which are as you know
the results of the splitting of Latin
Latin split into these five in fact much
more but this five main so-called Latin
languages in that case when we say that
late in his dad's this I will
how long is left
well I'm going to to mention now among
the in the chapter she devoted the
resurrection I'm going to talk about
that now well has let'em disappeared no
to the extent that Layton has given way
and has been the source from which other
languages have developed yes it has the
P to the extent that Spanish is not
Latin French isn't either
in spite of that I'd like to call your
attention to the fact that the reason
for me I have also doubt in two books
which confirmed this position the reason
why America was called Latin why would
America be Latin of course we are so
used to such a designation that we do
not wonder why but why did the Spanish
when they invaded aids the
conquistadores why did they call it
Latin the reason is that they considered
themselves bearers of Latin in other
words in spite of the fact that the
Castilian the purest termination of of
Spanish was no more was no longer since
centuries and centuries Latin they still
believed they were still convinced that
what they spoke was Latin eliten
transform to some extent but Latin and
is the way the reason why Hispanic
America was called Latin America
although it was not letting in any by
any means but is the way the Spaniards
viewed it well now in other cases
languages try to defend themselves
against the sorts of languages of
invaders and to resist and to try to
avoid dying well now let me as a one of
the last parts of this talk let me as I
announced say what I think about the
attempts to revive some languages there
are some attempts to revive languages
and some of them are successful some are
less some are not at all
what are these attempts many people
mostly missionaries and linguists do not
satisfy themselves with the simple
statement that language are being
extinct and progressively dying they try
to revive it them and in some cases
against the will of the population
themselves I mean to the extent that as
I said in the beginning of this talk
populations for various causes which I
referred to consider that they do not
have to transmit their vernacular
languages to their descendants with
their children to that extent when a
linguist or missionary a missionary to
translate the Bible in order to
evangelize the population in their own
vernacular a traditional language and
the linguist who is as myself along his
lover and who mourns the death of a
language as a catastrophe there was two
kind of men who do not coincide as you
can imagine except that some
missionaries have had linguistic
training of late because formerly they
did not they translated without knowing
the language no one you know how they
managed but anyway so these two kind of
persons exert a certain pressure on
their populations who are tempted to
abandon the languages and as a result
they try to find arguments here is the
plan of action which is proposed to help
protect against the loss of Indian
languages in many Indian Reservation in
America and also in Australia promoting
ethnic self-awareness confront
confronting apathy among young people
identifying social context in which
traditional languages you language use
can be fostered fighting against the
perception that multilingualism is
cumbersome and without great benefits
this is what I myself very often do as a
result there are some cases in which
languages escaped or at least provide
early escape death let me mention some
examples one of them concerns
Indian reserve United States at the
beginning of the sixteenth century in
the lands that are now the United States
I mean the 48 contiguous states plus
Alaska and Hawaii there must have been
many hundreds of distinct languages did
you know that you imagine that it's not
what your teachers tell you well fewer
than 200 still remain and the future of
these is decidedly insecure even where
the remoteness of the location in the
case of the Inuit Eskimo of northern
Alaska or the large size of the speech
community in the case of whom Navajos of
Arizona should normally or seemed to
protect the community from language loss
so people launch programs of revival in
order to help these languages not die
and to make populations aware of the
danger which threatens these languages
and threatens them to extinction and
this has the result that some of these
languages have been revived although to
some extent artificially but not without
success I can mention the case of Mohawk
you have heard of Mohawk which is still
spoken as well as other Iroquois and
family because they it belongs to the
Iroquois family which was firmly spoken
around the Great Lakes in their Chicago
and Detroit region thanks to the Mohawk
language immersion program the children
learned many of the positive phases of
Mohawk culture beyond the sounds and
phrases them a hot language emphasis is
also placed on traditional spirituality
and respect for teachers and elders
which makes part of their culture the
children can identify with mohawk role
models along with completing all that is
required academically the children have
a feeling of pride of knowing their own
language the feeling of security of
knowing the heritage and culture and the
confidence of a strong
identity it has taken 25 years to arrive
at where people are now it has been a
struggle but tremendously satisfying and
my informants say we still have to
contend with getting the community more
involved so we are far from being able
to sit back on our laurels so this is a
kind of fighting almost a warlike
campaign against death now some of them
have succeeded in making the political
authorities conscious before I mentioned
this fact let me also mention in other
case of successful fighting against
language death this applies to Beach
Spring in Arizona we may have heard of
that this is the place where the
Hualapai language used to be spoken and
at the beginning of the 20th century it
was very very severely threatened so
people reacted and now almost all of the
teaching staff of the peach Springs
program have attended the American
Indian language development Institute's
which was co-founded by the program's
director and as a result of access to
highly trained consultants and
researchers their speech Springs
bilingual bicultural program has
produced a great many highly accurate
culturally relevant and attractive books
and materials in the Hualapai language
one of the most threatened among these
languages which belong to the UK family
the program's publications include books
on Hualapai ethnobotany cattle ranching
hunting traditional foods and
traditional Hualapai history and stories
that children in the school have also
been involved in creative writing
programs creating contemporary short
stories life experience writing and
poetry in their vernacular Hualapai
language now people have done even
further in 1979 an American Indian
language development Institute ail G I
was founded and in June 1988 the
Internet
nor conference of this after the Native
American language issues Institute's
held a conference in Tempe Arizona
this conference in the course of the
conference all Indian and non-indian
participants including Hawaiian
representatives worked together to
formulate resolutions concerning Native
American language and cultures in
September a copy of these resolutions
was sent to the Select Committee of of
Indian Affairs and later in 1990 October
a bill was passed by the Senate and the
house and it was signed by President
Bush the other President Bush the
legislation is known as public law 101
or Native American language act what
does it contain let me just mentioned
from articles it says it is the policy
of the United States to first preserve
protect and promote the rise of and
freedom of Native Americans to use
practice and develop Native American
languages seconds and Crow agents
support the use of Native American
languages as a medium of instruction in
order to encourage and support Native
American language survival educational
opportunity increased student success
performance and so on the bill
unfortunately at the end in a last and
little visible chapter also states
that's nothing in this title shall be
construed as precluding the use of
federal funds to teach English to Native
Americans this is enough to for me not
to have to command upon you know what
this implies now let me in order to say
my last words hopefully say the reason
why the situation as a matter of fact is
not so dramatic as it might appear this
is because the comparison which I
referred to as to a large extent
metaphorical and consequently not quite
scientific between languages and living
species has its limits to the extent
that one as I as I announced property of
living species I mean the fact that they
die is not shared by languages languages
in fact do not die what does that mean
very simple thing in order to understand
what it implies you have to know that we
this is a professional linguist
distinction stomach science is technical
but I think everybody are some of you
linguists made on linguistics none of
you some of you so you must know that we
distinguish since the great Swiss French
linguist failed in all the social whom
you may have heard we distinguish
between peril and long language as a
system and speech as the use of this
system long our language as an abstract
notion means any instrument of
communication which possesses a phonetic
system because you need sounds in order
to make to fabricate words a morphology
which is a study of the external form of
words because you need words made of
sounds in order to be the vectors of
semantic contents then syntax because
you need a environment in order to build
sentences in the framework of which
these words will be put and there so it
is the job of syntax to study this and
finally you need semantics which is the
study of the content of these words
which are made of sounds which are which
this sounds constituting together them
the morphemes and these morphemes
together according to a certain word
order constituting sentences so this is
the system the language you can study
this in any language of the world and
another parameter another direction of
language is speech what French called
parallel what does it mean it means the
way
you put all that into use the way you
utilize these performance possibilities
in order to communicate and this is the
only things which in fact dies but
language is a system phonetic
morphologic syntactic and semantic does
not die why doesn't it not die for a
simple reason why should it die when we
say that language is dead we mean that
parole is dead it means that it is out
of usage people do not use it any longer
but provided we have kept a description
of this language of course in the
opposite case it is completely dead and
without any hope hopelessly however when
we have kept descriptions written as is
often the case either by missionaries or
by grammarians what used to be Graham is
formerly and what is to beat today
linguists professionally with like
myself when we have descriptions then
provided we can exploit them provided we
can tap them and see what they describe
other language which is called dad which
is assumed had disappeared we can revive
this language because we know on what
basis to revive this and this is what
has been done in at least one very
special case which I cannot and not
mention to and my talk and this is the
case of Hebrew I cannot avoid mentioning
it because it is although reconstituted
revived in is very special and probably
difficult to reproduce in very special
circumstances it has been revived as a
matter of fact and this of course cannot
not be cited as a model what that is
consists of you probably know that when
Yeshua of Nazareth the Jewish way of
calling him he was Joshua and Nazareth
was the city in which he lived he was
born in Bethlehem but Bethlehem which
means the house of bread but his house
and lehem is the bread bread he was born
in the house of bread but he spent most
of his life in a syrette and
Jewish way of calling him of course we
do not recognize Jesus Christ Christ
means being honored this is Christ
Catholic it does not be non to our
culture so I call it the Jewish way
Jesus of Nazareth which was his name for
his contemporaries when he appeared
Hebrew was already a dead language and
had been such for 500 years 600 years
why because in - 594 the Jews were
exiled in new nowhere in Babylon
why because Nebuchadnezzar whose name is
written a very well-known Virgie opera
la boca dinozzo nabuchadnezzar in a
Syrian language had fought against the
Judea and defeated the Jews and the Jews
alights elites alights elites the
aristocracy the king himself and all the
ones who ruled and high blue colors of
that epoch all these people were exiled
and they were forced to go to Babylon
and of course then six centuries before
the birth of Joshua of Nazareth they
spoke Hebrew but then being exiled in
Babylon they progressively adopted the
language which was very widespread then
in what we call Near East today and
these things we know what it was it was
aramean not armenian aramean which is
not yet dead probably the oldest still
remaining still living language in the
world which is still spoken today of
course in a new form in a modern form in
the heights of some Lebanese mountains
and this aramean language became
although originally it did not belong to
the Jews it became a very Jewish
negligent in a way because it was
adopted by Jewish edits after and after
the exile when they came back to
Jerusalem they did not speak Hebrew
anymore what did they speak aramean so
yahushua of nazareth spoke aramean like
all his contemporaries and he very
probably we are pretty sure that the way
the language in which he answered the
accusations
when he was sued was Iranian
of course she the Rabbie's rabbis asked
him whether he knew their prayers he did
and he probably said the price in Hebrew
because Hebrew was and still is in
Jewish communities today there are
English our flight raja the language
which is used in the synagogue and which
is a religious language but as soon as
the birth of Christ at escala him the
Christian Way as soon as the birth of
Christ Hebrew was already dead and it
was so since six centuries before so in
1948 the State of Israel was created by
a vote in the United Nations which
unfortunately as soon as it was
published brought about the dramatic
departure of all the representatives of
Arabic countries they all stood up and
they left the hall in which this
selection had taken place as a kind of
symbolic rejection at the very beginning
of the creation of Israel this of course
you know the results still today under
our eyes of this situation however when
this states in such a difficult context
was created by an international
resolution then the Hebrew language had
already began to be revived how because
there was a man of course it's not the
work of a single man you have heard
probably of Ben Yehuda when Yehuda was a
Jewish Russian who at the end of the
19th century all of a sudden became
aware of the fact that it was not enough
most of these people were scientists not
in the very derogative science of today
unfortunately the scientists then meant
an ideal of liberation to be scientists
at the end of 19th century as many hada
was implied to be inhabited by a desire
to free their Jewish people from
slavery and formed from Caesar from
anti-semitism and all his or its
negative aspect of its history so they
were scientists in this in this meaning
to which in order to free themselves
from their binds and then he all of a
sudden became aware that in order to be
able to go in Palestine the Jews had to
speak a language which was which should
be coming to all of them and then many
Jews this is was far very long before
the creation of Israel it was in the
beginning of the 20th century and of the
19th and begin of the 20th many Jews
made what we call in Hebrew Aliyah they
went to Palestine many of them came from
Russia because as you know the Tsarist
Russia had many many programs and the
Jews were obliged to to flee from Russia
in order to avoid murder slaughter and
then they went to Palestine which was
then a Turkish province administered and
ruled by consents in Oppel by the Turks
then in 1948 when the State of Israel
was created Hebrew was already a spoken
language thanks to the efforts of Ben
Yehuda and other ones who spent almost
whole life looking for words of the
Bible modernizing the language of course
the Bible does not contain words to say
atomic bomb or airplane or terrorism and
so on notions which belong to our
context cultural context but they made
up this words they invented they coined
new words and this neurological work
which was extremely important took years
and years during which a new language
not quite new but a modernization of
Hebrew finally was possible and this
which is called Israeli Hebrew who was
in fact a revival of Hebrew why because
the syntax the morphology of course the
as I said is renewed but the the core of
the language syntax morphology and also
phonology to the extent that we know how
they pronounced three century three
million Aries ago where the same as
those of Biblical Hebrew so bi miracle
Hebrew and the IH b h b because hebrew
nih is surely hebrew our moral as the
same language of course with differences
which can be explained easily when you
think after the period of time which
separates them so this language was
revived when I say revived they mean
that not only was Hebrew a dead language
as soon as the beginning of the
Christian era as I said due to the
Babylon exile but also Hebrew had never
been used except in quite and
exclusively religious context it was the
language of tad nudists of rabbis in
their scientific correspondence have
flown it people but not the English in
which we say to a girl I love you or to
your father please they give me a fork
or a spoon when you are eating so it was
a language which was used exclusively in
very solemn and very religious
circumstances never in everyday life
this is the reason why I said it was
dead because the language which was used
exclusively between loaded people and in
written form but not in our form is a
dead language however I mentioned the
example to terminate this a talk as a
proof that when the language has been
described when we have many many texts
the main of them being the Bible itself
then in spite of its having disappeared
in spite of its having never been used
during menus and memories it is not
quite that because it can be revived
since we have the testimonies we have
the elements of course this is one thing
which is requested another one is a
certain will a collective will a very
strong will shared by many people to
revive a language of which we have at
our disposal of materials this will as
far as I know to the best of my
knowledge has never been treated
exclusively
excluding among the Jews but I think
this is a model to be exploited to be
utilized as a things to be imitated by
other communities the the inhabitants of
Cornwall in England in the South of
England have tried along this model to
revive Cornish Cornish was dead at the
end of the 17th century and their corn
the the how do ii was Cornish who of
course speak English and have done so
for Central centuries said we are not
Jews in fact they are not true but we
why wouldn't we try to say to do the
same thing as the Jews days and so they
have succeeded against all expectations
they very very clear in in art success
that has succeeded to at dazzling speeds
Tory is reviving their language along
the model of Hebrew we are we have some
other cases which are Creoles such as
the one used in the East of Timor and
also the one nagamimi is used in
nagaland which is a Himalayan States at
the extreme northeast of India we have
some other examples but they the only
one we can mention and which is a true
one is Hebrew revived Hebrew and this
illustrates once more as I said the fact
that when parallel I mean the use in
everyday speech is the only parameter
which has disappear but language itself
has not because it is described then if
I dare say so it suffices to have a
collective will to revive the language
of course this collective will does not
always exist and the destiny the fate of
the Jewish people is not a fate which is
very common as you may know so this is
the last thing I wanted to mention in
order to show no my last last thing is
that
other than Hebrew we can mention facts
which relieve us from this despair from
the disparate inglesa from this
situation in which we see so many
languages dying we have also some
languages which appear from nothing from
scratch and these languages are Creoles
this is well known I am myself
acquiesced realistic I would like to
remark to recall realistic is one of the
most vivid and most active disciplines
within linguistics
I am Aquarius myself why because we see
in West Indies in New Hebrides in other
parts of the world we know languages are
extremely young we can assign them to
office centuries and we know when they
were born when they appeared and these
Creoles are engraved have been created a
fleet two or three centuries ago in the
for the oldest of them by populations
which were deprived of languages due to
sleep due to slavery and to a very sad
history which you may know so the birth
of Creoles of course does not compensate
for the the death of so many languages
but it is a fact to be mentioned as a
sign of hope that when many language
died some languages also appear and this
process might go on during centuries and
centuries
I believe thank you very much for
attention
[Applause]
yes but this this is precisely why I say
that the metaphorical comparison of
language with living species finds its
limitations in this theory argument
species when they are dead are dead
definitely which is not the case of
languages they see exactly what I said
you cannot revive a issue an
entomologist you know that a special
species of insects has appeared from the
from the earth for economical ecological
reasons that you can study then no one
will be able to revive it which is not
the case of languages provided you have
a situation like the ones I referred to
and your other question because you know
whether we're born would you like some
examples you know the situation well
well you know I you know I have I have
myself
well Haitian you say yeah well I know
well I know better although it's more
less the same because they can't
communicate without difficulty I know
better the ones which belong to French
territories still today which are the
one of Guadeloupe Martinique and we are
we know we were well when I speak of
Creole appearing at a certain date it is
because we can date their appearance and
why this is like this is related to the
history of slavery you know African
communities were taken away from their
tribes where they lived by merchants
which who were Spain Spanish French
mainly British but also from other
countries Portuguese they were bought
from locally
and then as soon as they embarked in
these boats which led them to the
carnies the trade were mixed up and
their languages we're being disappearing
then it's in well-known stories lies for
recording because you know it is well
known then they're obliged to create new
means of communication in order to
communicate and what they create was a
kind of new language in which they took
some things from the language of the
masters French English Spanish as the
case may be and some other elements from
their own vernacular languages and this
is why realistic has become such an
important part of linguistic because we
have great controversies we have what we
call the sub Stratus and the anti
subsidized I am a substitute I mean I am
among the those I am an African is
myself so I have many studied many many
African languages and I recognize I
identify in Creoles many African
features which cannot be explained by
French English or Spanish and the anti
Creole lists they retain other features
which are the same as the ones in
European languages and they say no you
cannot be a sub Stratis we are anti
substrata so the controversy consists of
saying what are the traits the features
which are due to the African origin of
slaves and what are the ones which are
assigned more to the rhymes of the
Masters which are European languages I
didn't say it is difference I just say
tis more recent no no I don't say that I
don't you I understand what you imply
I'm not saying that Krios are something
quite apart and not to be compared with
other kind of language they are human
language like any other I just say that
they are by far younger than the one you
know why because the origin of Latin and
Greek is extremely remote and we don't
have in F da kyumin's the origin of
Creoles RV is very recent because we
know when these slave slavery
circumstances began we know most of the
African languages still in use of course
which were the ones of the tribes to
which this place belonged and then the
only thing I say is not that they are
different by any means but still but
they are younger because we know
and when they appeared this is what I
say
most Creoles will have the same language
because we will be the reason among yes
just a minute
among the reason we mentioned for giving
toot realistic such an important place
within our studies is that not only this
controversy between subsidies and anti
subsidies is in fact a very important
[Music]
theoretical question in linguistics
because it in fact refers to what
language is and how does a language
appear so Creoles provide us arguments
in one or other direction the other
reason is as I said that we know when
they appear and then what we cannot do
for Latin Hebrew Arabic and other
languages of which old documents have
disappeared we can do for Krios because
we have documents missionaries who
eventual eyes these the slaves spoke
African languages with them just tried
them and they saw they were the witness
of the birth of this language they saw
them appearing progressively and we have
descriptions great number this is why
realistics to me and to many other
linguists a such an important domain in
linguistics yes
what on internet I see I see Internet as
a big chance for the diversity for
multilingualism because in the beginning
internet appeared wrongly we thought
appeared as one more way of promoting
English but progressively Internet was
people became aware of the possibility
which was provided by Internet to
promote their own languages and now what
I see myself on almost every day is that
many many sites are occupied by
languages which we do not have expected
to to appear on internet so internet for
me right now is one of the best ways to
preserve language from disappearing it
was not the question
new what do you mean by new which ones
you mean new human language or made-up
languages it excuse me excuse me I am a
professional linguist I would not call
this way of communications languages a
language for me is what you know it has
a history it has a grammar it is not
exclusively in written form on the
screen or your internet of your computer
its language we spoken so the codes I
would call them curves which appear and
which are very numerous they invade in a
way Internet do not disturb me they are
not languages they are codes or means of
communicating communication which of
course probably are very useful to many
people use them but I would not study
them within my work as a linguist yes
associated with what what I say yes you
are correct he is quite correct what he
said is X I would he caught what I meant
yes it was a comment
to some sense they did
they don't bark well there is a piece of
information which is lacking and which I
would like to provide you in fact these
people had what we call vehicular
languages in the Amazon in the Great
Plains among the Algonquin say Rockies
and so on
there were many bakero languages I mean
languages whose origin was taken from
one of the tribes and which impose
themselves on all of the tribes and they
were used as communication languages
this is what the Y's found when they
arrived in all these contexts we had
they have been described as some
missionaries and we have some some
elements of information on them in all
these communities which where it is true
split up into many many tribes they
communicate with each other through the
use of these vehicular languages no no
but this is much later but this is much
later there is a kind of anachronism a
very construction of a series gasps back
to a remote antiquity which I would
assign to nine or ten thousand years
before the beginning of the Christian
era where while the period you are
referring to is the arrive of the whites
in America which is the sixteenth
century between the two we have ten
hundred ten thousand and six centuries
so there's not the same period any norms
[Music]
lack of time for in the tooth
after yes do you agree with it what what
do you propose what do you propose
well no no what I say what I say is that
we we state which states in thing which
can be observed that the increased
number of languages corresponds to the
increased number of social relationships
in English which we know which has been
described
so of course starting from this point
which is recognized agreed upon by most
scholars what I say is to some extent
hypotheticals true but I would not deny
many other linguists also have this view
claim that sedan-chair life multiplied
increased as a result increased the
number of languages because languages
are way by which human societies react
to the complexity of life in order to
communicate so it doesn't mean that
nomads had simple languages they had
fewer but in fact the language of
Australia which have been conserved and
of erosional Duncan tribes in America
going back to a very old period of time
are very complicated so what I say is
not that when you have hunter-gatherer
societies becoming becoming sedentary
they have more complex languages they
have many more languages I say which are
not necessarily less more complex that
but they multiply the number because
themselves multiply the settlements and
circumstances in which they live this is
what I say to some extent I repeat its
hypothetical so you just
if I'd to put it into question but it is
an opinion which is shared by many
linguists not quite demonstra ball I've
got nice yes what areas New Guinea yes
is not smaller what's your question
oh it's a very easy to reconcile we I
would say for ecological reasons because
as you may know the part of the world in
which we have many many tribes picking
many different language diverging
languages which do not allow despite the
existence of 800 languages in easy
communication all of these parts of the
world New Guinea northern territories of
Australia and so on are very mountainous
were places in which people to the
Caucasus also in which people are
separated by relief accidents which are
very high so the way social linguistics
tries to explain this proposal of course
which can be improved the way social
linguist try to explain this situation
as being non contradictory is that this
is related to the
geographical configurations of these
countries and we know you know we have
been myself to New Guinea we have a
central chain which is extremely
inaccessible and in which it turns out
that it is the way the very one in which
we have the most probably the most the
most important number of language in the
worlds in New Guinea and the other one
is Caucasus for the same reasons so
these people of course acidentally they
are in cities they are they live more or
less in societies which do not know me
dies any longer and have not done it for
centuries and centuries but they are
split up in many many languages because
the communication is made difficult by
as opposed to that we know we have the
opposite example we know that the
islands which have no no mountains which
are quite flat like Samoa like New
Caledonia like Tonga have few languages
very few and since these people even
when there was a great distance of sea
of Mara in territory these scenes people
where navigators and we're always
related to to do commerce between them
these are places in which we have very
few languages there is one triangle
language there is one Fijian Fiji and so
on as opposed to carcasses New Guinea
and other mountainous part of the world
which are a proliferation or languages
this for me is precisely social
linguistics itself we explain language
differentiation and multiplication by
ecological conditions the way we try to
explain it yes
and I think if we think of language as a
repertoire and also a focus of culture
in itself that's why we feel that the
loss of language is tragic because it
represents the loss of culture however
it seems to me there is a case to be
made that language is sort of flexible
over culture that they don't coincide or
monikers there are cases of obliteration
the American Indian case where language
and culture loss are sort of coincident
you get alliteration of culture followed
by language loss but there are also many
cases and I think some of the evidence
for this is linguistic areas or cultural
areas where you get cultural forms that
include lexical field grammatical forms
and even aesthetic forms like poetic
genre that spread across language back
to Southeast Asia is a great cultural
convergence Center for example where all
the languages like these Thai Chinese
somehow these features that we associate
with particular cultural spreading
across language lines the Hebrew case
you mentioned there's another
interesting case where Hebrew was
replaced by Aramaic suggested something
survived through this
well there are many things mixed up
together and what you say first of all I
will by the way if I may ask will you be
here tomorrow tomorrow I will give a
talk in which I will mention English's
and it will be devoted to this very
subject to what extent English and other
languages I will talk about that in this
I am very interested in this subject
however in what you say when you started
speaking I wondered whether you were
going to say that if languages appears
culture does not disappear but you
switch it to another subject and this is
the beginning of you of your question
and I quite agree that language death
when it is the loss of a language PI
population does not imply necessarily
cultural death I thought you were going
to mention gastronomy dancing poetry
there are many cultural forms which
belong in culture but we do not consult
with language and in this country we
know that the only ones who are able to
cook things which you can taste are
people coming from old countries in
which one knew how to cook food
and in that case I must say that even in
those cases in which people lose their
languages to English they do not lose
other part of a cultures including
astronomy which are you know French
people are very interested in but you
then switch it to another aspect which
is also very interesting which has
excuse me nothing to do which was with
what you started with which is borrowing
between languages transferring by
borrowing this is quite true I quite
agree
you mentioned Southeast Asian languages
thai mayor Burmese Chinese are languages
which were whose bearers who spoke
speakers we're always in relationship
during centuries and centuries and of
course we know Vietnamese is a mixing up
of Thai and Chinese it is a Creoles Thai
with many Chinese borrowing I myself I
chart Chinese very long and I lived in
China joined years and years and of
course during this time I was a
so-called sino-tibetan East or Burma
Burma sea chiba-chiba Toberman East and
I studied this aspect of the things and
what I said what I saw I can say is that
then as you yourself say these languages
constituted and still go on considering
today a kind of set between between the
parts of which were circulated and where
borrowed or given back and so on as far
as Hebrew is concerned
a third part of your small talk I would
say I would say speaking Hebrew as the
Jews did up to or down to the Babylonian
exile then switching to aramean then
reviving Hebrew in the first half of the
twentieth century is a special case of
language death and language resurrection
but if you if the the the core of your
argument is that there are various types
of language death I quite agree it's
true and if it is it was not clear in
I talk is because my talk was bad
because it's exactly what I wanted to
say I quite agree that we have various
versions of language death this is quite
true and thank you very much
another question
European expression in what meaning
integration what's your question you
know I am a language lover and minority
languages I love as much as any other
languages so Catalan Basque was the name
of this language in the no waste of
Spain hmm Gallego El Gallego was
terrorist when y'all got very good I'm
bien de pano say not let's play Venus of
lava so we move facility not ok smile
means miss me DOMA and transistor so
therefore these languages of course I am
for their defense and I don't think
their fate is so dim it might be a
brilliant future which is in front of
them why because as you may know the
ones who promote these languages have
understood that what the central
government refused blue cells and
unified Europe can't except can accept
and this is reason why most of the
defenders and promoters of these
regional languages whether they are
called regional languages address
themselves to Brussels when they don't
obtain a fulfilment of their requests
from Paris Madrid or Rome so I think
that the few
our original image in Europe is by no
means threatens as much probably as the
one of the great languages themselves
this might sound contradictory but I'm
afraid it might turn out to be true so
I'm not afraid for as far as these
angles are concerns or not not as more
as much as for French Spanish and German
or Italian
[Applause]